messieurs merci d'être avec ton direct
sur rt france alors parlons benedetti
mouvement de contestation on l'a vu
paris toulouse lyon
est-ce que selon vous c'est un mouvement
qui prend de l'ampleur
en tout cas c'est un mouvement qui
s'installe dans la durée depuis
maintenant trois semaines un mouvement
qui gagne ont eu droit que manifestement
aujourd'hui la mobilisation semble plus
massive de cadeaux étaient encore samedi
dernier qui gagne en amplitude
territoriales ce qui est très
intéressant c'est de voir que plusieurs
villes parfois des petites villes ont vu
des dessinée de manifestants se
mobiliser pour dire non ce pass
sanitaires l'autre aspect qui me paraît
important c'est l'hétérogénéité de cette
mobilisation
on voit bien que les motivations de vps
vous avez des gens qui ne sont pas
d'ailleurs hostiles au vaccin mais qui
pose la question qui est la question des
libertés publiques la question des
libertés fondamentales d'ailleurs que
devra examiner le conseil
constitutionnel dans quelques jours
puisque le texte de loi était déféré
devant le conseil constitutionnel
et puis d'autres qui ont en effet un
certain nombre de tout compte disent non
à la question d'une action que je crois
qu'il ya en effet un mouvement qu'il a
et 3 très hétérogène qui sont dans tout
cas c'est l'hystérie pour l'instant
entonnant besser vous êtes avocat de
droit la prochaine étape c'est le
conseil constitutionnel qui doit statuer
comme son nom l'indiqué sur la
constitutionnalité de ce texte de loi le
délai
on donne institution est il assez
important finalement le conseil
constitutionnel a parfaitement
l'habitude de
rendre des décisions rapidement on le
voit depuis 2015 a minima avec toutes
les lois terroristes il est habitué à
traiter ce genre de questions dans
l'urgence ouais j'ai consulté la journée
du conseil constitutionnel l'a l'instant
il va rendre trois décisions en les skis
pour des lois qui ont été qui ont toutes
été votées
d'après ce que j'ai compris 25 juillet
ça lui laisse 11 jours et dispose de
services extrêmement compétents et la
question est très souvent au delà d'une
jurisprudence constitutionnelle elle
reste aussi à ces politiques donc débat
va surtout je pense tourner autour de la
question de savoir est ce que la
situation autorise le parlement
aujourd'hui à prendre les décisions
qu'il a prises
mais le le débat va devoir à mon sens
aussi se tourner sur la question non pas
des libertés fondamentales mais sur la
question du de la compétence du
parlement et du gouvernement puisque on
a une démocratie je le rappelle depuis
plusieurs siècles parlementaire hors la
loi délègue au premier ministre et au
préfet donc à l'autorité réglementaire
administrative un certain nombre de
pouvoirs et où tafer exorbitants et je
le rappelle aujourd'hui on est dans une
stratégie de sortie de crise sanitaire
l'état d'urgence sanitaire n'est plus en
application
ah non benedetti se passe sanitaire ne
comporte t-il pas un risque justement
l'effet inverse braquer les plus
réticents
oui c'est vrai que en l'occurrence on
pouvait lorsqu'il ya eu les annonces du
président de la république le 12 juillet
penser que les françaises et les
français qui est jusqu'à présent
finalement avait fait preuve même s'il
avait été très critique sur la gestion
de cette épidémie par le gouvernement
mais avait en règle générale accepté
[Musique]
quel que soit finalement les dispositifs
qui a été mis en place par le
gouvernement
les contraintes auxquelles les
astreignez les pouvoirs publics dans la
gestion quand une fois de cette crise
sanitaire là pour la première fois on
assiste quand même à une mobilisation
qui est une mobilisation importante dans
la rue
au coeur de l'été faut-il le souligner
et l'on voit que les études d'opinion
sont en train d'évoluer il ya cela à
plus tard que 24 heures un sondage louis
harris montré que 40% des français
soutenaient le mouvement et 50 % visés
le comprendre on est déjà très loin des
chiffres des premiers chiffres que les
instituts de sondage avait mis en avant
suite aux déclarations du président de
la république je crois que ya plusieurs
sujets des premiers sujets en effet
c'est quand même une question
fondamentale est-ce que les mesures qui
sont prises aujourd'hui sont
proportionnelles au regard des objectifs
qui sont fixés et est ce que finalement
mettre entre parenthèses un certain
nombre de principes qui sont des
principes d'égalité des pratiques de
liga t est justifiée par la situation
sanitaire ça c'est une question qui me
semble qu'ils aient une question
matricielle le deuxième sujet qui est
tout aussi important c'est de savoir si
aujourd'hui l'opinion publique et en os
mesure d'accepter des contraintes
supplémentaires avec quand même un grand
état d'incertitude qui semble ont
continué à régner la certitude sur la
circulation du virus incertitudes
sur la solidité ou non de la couverture
n'est dit de la couverture pardon
vaccinale donc ce climat est assez
anxiogène et montre quand même d'une
certaine manière que aujourd'hui une
partie de la société semble en tout cas
douter voire en tout cas parfois il
mécontente du dispositif qui est mis en
place
je rajouterais un dernier point très
important c'est que la communication de
l'exécutif ces dernières semaines n'a
pas été une communication d'apaisement
souvenons nous des propos du jeune
secrétaire d'état porte parole du
gouvernement
quand ils verront que les gt1 enfants
qui manifestent constitue une frange
minoritaire est capricieuse on a là une
communication qui n'est pas sans
rappeler celle qui avait été celle des
pouvoirs publics au moment du démarrage
décidé jaune une communication qui
mettait plutôt jolie chaise sur les
plaies plutôt que d'essayer d'apaiser la
société française
benedetti vous venez de parler de la
communication du gouvernement justement
entonnant aux pêcheurs pourquoi selon
vous certains français doutent encore de
l'utilité et de l'efficacité du vaccin
est ce que il ya des failles au niveau
justement de la communication du
gouvernement français de tout de toute
évidence le gouvernement a communiqué
passez moi le terme et n'importe comment
moi même qui est quelques notions de
sciences je suis absolument pas
convaincu de l'efficacité de ce vaccin
je me renseignais m'ont énormément sur
les chiffres et comme monsieur bennett
il souligne très justement est ce que ne
font pas certains médias mainstream
aujourd'hui qui oppose les 35 millions
de vaccinés avec ceux qui manifestent
aujourd'hui
en réalité les manifestants sont
extrêmement divers dans leurs origines
et leurs opinions
il ya beaucoup de vacciner qui qui qui
vont manifester contre cette loi qui est
absolument liberticide qui marque la fin
de l'état libéral qu'on connaît depuis
la révolution française qu'on à a
chèrement acquise le
c'est cette diversité est la marque
d'une d'une incompréhension généralisée
ici c'est pas ces manifestations sont
pas l'apanage d'un groupe politique qui
à politiser la question c'est le
gouvernement ce débat n'a rien de
sanitaires il est il est absolument
politique et vous avez l'ensemble des la
représentation politique française qui
manifestent aujourd'hui que ce soit du
militant haut responsable politique
donc le gouvernement doit reculer sur
cette question c'est un style il va
créer un précédent en précédant
politique et législatif puisque
l'assemblée nationale votre les yeux
fermés depuis l'élection d' emmanuel
macron à précédent politique qui ouvre
la voie à des dérives anti libérale qui
sont inacceptables dans notre pays
armand benedetti convaincre les
bénéfices d'une vaccination massive on a
bien vu en le gouvernement français a
échoué là dessus pourquoi selon vous
parce que depuis le début le
gouvernement emmanuel macron lui même
ils sont allés en ayant le bras qui
tremble
souvenez vous quand on regarde
l'histoire de cette crise sanitaire et
de la façon dont la politique vaccinale
a été mise en avant
on a eu une année dernière par exemple à
la même époque un président de la
république qui doutaient de la de la
capacité à développer des vaccins dans
le court même des 12 mois qui suivaient
on avait ensuite un président de la
république qui est à une vers le mans
qui quand même on y en place une
stratégie vaccinale qui a mis du temps à
démarrer
quatre mois ce qui s'est passé par
exemple au royaume uni en israël
tout s'est passé finalement dans la
partie d'un lot dans la stratégie du
gouvernement en ce qui concerne les
vaccins qu'on s'y malgré tout l'exécutif
avait intérieur et intérioriser de
manière inconsciente un certain nombre
de prévention de
opinion publique on a eu dans la
communication dans la mise en oeuvre
opérationnelle de la stratégie vaccinale
toute une chaîne de ratés qui
indéniablement fait qu'aujourd'hui une
partie de l'opinion publique
certes peut-être minoritaire mais
doutent de l'efficacité des vaccins y
compris d'ailleurs ce parfois qu'ils
vont se faire vacciner beaucoup vont se
faire vacciner
considérant que les risques d'effets
secondaires sont peut-être très faible
mais qui ne sont pas les plus convaincus
de l'efficacité à venir du vaccin
donc il ya là récemment dans la dans la
façon dont l'exécutif a présenté cette
politique a mis en oeuvre cette
politique bien des racines qui explique
aujourd'hui qu'en france il y est en
effet une opinion publique qui
apparaissent pour une partie d'entre
elles à selective à la stratégie est
aujourd'hui proposée par l'exécutif
monsieur benedetti monsieur pêcheurs
fait désolé un homme pressé par le temps
je vais devoir terminer maintenant merci
à vous d'avoir été avec nous à arnaud
benedetti je rappelle que vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire ans thomas peschard
vous êtes avocat au barreau de paris
merci à tous les deux mesures